welcome back everyone to
vintage egyptologist here on youtube
today we're going to delve into a little
bit more detail
into the orientation of hieroglyphs
so if you haven't seen part one take a
moment
and watch that introduction and by the
end of our short lesson today
you will know where to start reading the
hieroglyphic text
as well as how it works when signs are
stacked
[Music]
[Applause]
for those of you who are well versed
already in hieroglyphic signs
i ask that you stay tuned to the end of
today's episode
where john will be joining me to discuss
perturbation
in new kingdom royal tombs and the
netherworld books
so let's get started with the first
portion
of our lesson we know
that when we look at a hieroglyphic text
we always read
towards the faces of the signs and
that's easy because
most hieroglyphic texts are going to
have an owl or a quail chick
or a representation of a person or a
body part
so you always know the direction to
start reading
this magnificent folio plate for the
temple of setting the first and abidos
is a perfect example of how the
egyptians used the orientation of
hieroglyphs
to create a unity of art and writing
so here we can see king seti the first
making an offering actually burning
incense
before the god osiris and his wife
isis in the scene
each of the figures has hieroglyphs
oriented
in the same way as what is being labeled
so we're going to work actually from the
far left here we can see the goddess
isis wearing the horns
and sundisk that she actually adopts
from the iconography of hathor
and she is labeled isis
the great mother of the god
the mistress of heaven those hieroglyphs
read right
to left the same direction in which isis
is facing now when you have a situation
in a vertical
column where you have hieroglyphs in a
square
you maintain the right to left
reading but then read top to bottom
within these smaller squares so
sat the first by literal in the name of
isis
t is a phonetic complement meaning that
it repeats the second
of the biliteral sounds and then an egg
which is a determinative that can be
used in the new kingdom
for the name of a goddess so that is
isis
another biliteral where which is the
bird
w-r followed by its phonetic complement
and then if we keep going again we see
the stacking
of signs for the word pet so the p
and the t reading across and then
the pet sign itself which is used both
as an ideogram
and a determinative
if we move to the next figure our green
faced osiris here we again see that the
hieroglyphs are facing the same way
as osiris we have the i and the set sign
that writes wessier the ancient name for
osiris we
typically use the hellenized the greek
version
and the seated god is the determinative
so osiris then a tri-literal
genti which means foremost and he is
foremost of the yementiu
the westerners now you meant you
is plural which is why we have three
strokes and when we get into the grammar
of nouns
we will talk about singular dual
and plural osiris has two additional
epithets
when nefer spelled with the desert hair
and the nefer sign and nebta
jesser lord of the sacred land with then
the three-hilled khasat sign the desert
sign
as the determinative so the two gods
facing to the right have their
hieroglyphs facing
the same direction as they are
when we turn next to king seti the first
we see the hieroglyphs change
orientation so that
now the label to seti is facing the same
way
as the king we see seti in this camp
crown
with urayus and the hieroglyphs that
label
him face left to right
just as he does and this says a
spell foreseen the god
this is part of the daily ritual
and then jed medu in
words spoken by and this is another
great example of you read the
je serpent first then the medustic
then the read leaf so every time you
come to
stacked signs you keep reading in the
overall direction
and then left to right across
or topped down depending on how they're
stacked
these are words spoken by the king and
the king is
neb tawi lord of the two lands
men ma'at ra that is the name of seti
the first
and you will notice that this cartouche
i read
bottom to top this is another principle
of hieroglyphic writing
called honorific transposition
if you have a word or a name that
includes the name of the god
or sometimes also in reference to the
king you
write the god's name first even though
you read it
last so you read min first
enduring ma'at
cosmic order of rey
so that is an example where the
orientation the order of the signs
is different than what you would expect
because of honorific transposition
so let's look at this introductory
section
on one of the sides of the second shrine
of tutankhamun
from the tomb of tutankhamun this is
based on
a segment of the otherwise better known
book of gates
so here we see two goddesses to either
side of a ram-headed pole
the ram head indicates youth
or flesh the night form of the sun god
and this goddess is adoring
as is this goddess this head of rey and
in fact it's labeled here
in more or less normal orthography
head of ra now these are the names
of the two goddesses now notice this
this isn't a common sign
it's a very uncommon sign it's a person
with their arms out
surrounded by a series of dots they're
swimming
this is the elaborate determinative
uh we might even say idiogram of to swim
which is nebi in the egyptian the verb
nevi
so it is followed by a cha
hobble so i've got nebich
then i've got a second age so aha
plosive h normal hieroglyph followed by
these three pronged
plant signs that can appear as
determinatives they can have the
phonetic value
hen but remember we mentioned
substitution
i can say well you know what i have a
plant sign here so i'm going to
substitute a plant sign
each of these substitutes for the
standard
read leaf the value yod or
can transcribe it almost as an i even so
this is an attested orthography of the
name
nebuchut that we know from the
hellenized form
much better as neftes so
this is a cryptographic orthography of
the name of the goddess nephews
and if we see nephews and we see another
goddess we can be fairly certain that
this
is in fact the goddess isis and it is
two shah signs shesh but
the first rectangular sign
which is a land or water sign can
substitute for another this can
substitute for the
island sign that has rounded edges
that has the phonetic value u and of
course the
wow being a weak consonant we can
disregard if we want to in cryptography
and sha remember our substitution i can
substitute one bird sign for another if
i want to i can play around with signs
based on their phonetic classification
sha
is a sibilant so it can substitute for
another
s so here we've got rather than shash
we've got you ish for is for us
isa for isis so we have isis and nephews
the head of rey
and cryptographically here men
the red crown net for n actually appears
in normal hieroglyphic text
a lot in ramisit period
nan m that's a sober substituting for
the
m owl m sa here
the elaborate we might say piece of
cloth with a belt
substituting just for that bolt of cloth
that's the normal s
so another substitution of kind nan m
secchiere pan the spewing mouth
for poo for poi pee
um it's like bilabial it literally is
demonstrating the plosive action of the
mouth and then
m sec your pen these are like this
menom secure pen
these are like this these exist in this
manner these gods are like this
this is a common introductory annotation
in the netherlands books
men and secure pen probably sheptep
receiving the head or those who receive
the head and then it says
if we look at these signs they're single
hieroglyphs so they're probably
substituting for single phonetic values
we've got um an n new for n
we have our saw bird that could be
standing for any
single uniliteral bird sign here's
probably an
m here we've got our three-pond
plant substituting for some plant sign
ah there's our elaborate say cloth with
the belt
so let's assume that might be s again
um and then there's a snake
now a snake can substitute for another
snake so here's an elaborate serpent
that usually
appears as a determinative what if it's
substituting for the horn viper
don't mean an f that would be an f now
if i read this
ness f something right well already
that's not not working doesn't what does
that mean well
what if it's retrograde then so um
that's
so i worked with this for a while then i
realized well
um an annotation that often appears with
deities that will appear with the king
etc is a protective
formula that describes life protection
etc being
all around someone and egyptian has this
interesting preposition
ha second h olive that literally means
around behind so it gets across this
notion of being around
not just behind as we often translate
it's like the wings of the horus falcon
in that great statue of khafra in the
cairo museum
ha yeah you're around behind so so what
i realized is
this is a really interesting use of
perturbation
so that when i read this text i am doing
what the goddesses are doing
it is sen em
ha this three pawn plant substituting
for the
ha sign three prime plant which is
something that we find
actually happening sometimes in normal
hieroglyphic texts based on
mistranscriptions out of the hierarchic
remember some of these signs look a lot
more similar in the cursive
than they look in the hieroglyphs so
some of the substitutions
in the cryptography are playing with the
possibilities out of hierarchy and then
transposing those into hieroglyphs
sen am ha f i read this circularly
they are all around him meaning in this
protective
gesture so the direction of reading of
hieroglyphs also has a magical aspect
to it reading in retrograde
reading in a circular fashion etc this
is
more for an ancient egyptian than just a
you know it's not a tongue twister this
is more than an eye
twister this is more than just messing
with something this can
literally cause you to make the
motion of backing up of going
back around something and the retrograde
motion
can relate to the concept of enchantment
for the egyptians
which is shiny pressure etc to go around
to encircle so retrograde writing
and perturbations mixing up of signs for
the ancient egyptians
can impart an even deeper or additional
meaning to a text
so we hope you enjoyed the episode today
from
simple orientation to some of the most
complex perturbation and cryptography
that there really is
in any ancient egyptian text
if you want to follow our vintage and
egyptological adventures
don't forget to give us a follow on
vintage egyptologists
on instagram if you haven't subscribed
yet here on youtube
please do so uh give us a few comments
suggestions for future episodes and
we'll make sure to include in the notes
references to all the books we're using
as well as where you can find more
information about how to read
hieroglyphs
[Music]
i